>> Tucker: THE F.B.I.
TONIGHT TAKING ANOTHER LOOK AT
THE CLINTON FOUNDATION.
SEARCHING FOR EVIDENCE THE
FOUNDATION MAY HAVE TAKEN
DONATIONS -- BRACE
TRACE GALLAGHER HAS MORE ON
THAT STORY.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
HEY, TRACE.
>> FOX NEWS LEARNED THE
U.S. ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND THE
F.B.I. HAVE BEEN LOOKING INTO
THE CLINTON FOUNDATION FOR
MONTHS.
THE FOCUS IS MAINLY ON THE PAY
TO PLAY POLITICS.
WE ARE TOLD A KEY WITNESS
INTERVIEWED IN DECEMBER
DEALING SPECIFICALLY WITH ANY
COMPARISONS BETWEEN DONATIONS
TO THE CLINTON FOUNDATION AND
OF STATE.
THAT IS THE FIRST
INVESTIGATION.
THERE IS ALSO HILLARY CLINTON
FEATURING FORMER F.B.I.
DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY ORIGINAL
NEGLIGENCE" AND SAYS THERE WAS
EVIDENCE THAT CLINTON
LANGUAGE IN THE DRAFT SO
CLINTON COULD AVOID CRIMINAL
CHARGES.
THE D.O.J. IS EXPLORING
WHETHER TO REOPEN THE PROBE.
EXPLAIN EVIDENCE GATHERED IN
THE NOW DOR MANT URANIUM ONE
SPECIAL COUNSEL MIGHT BE
NEEDED.
THAT IS THE 2010 TRANSACTION
WHERE THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
ALLOWED THE SALE OF
U.S. URANIUM MINING FACILITY
TO THE RUSSIA STATE RUN ENERGY
GIANT.
HILLARY RUN STATE DEPARTMENT
WAS ONE AMONG THE NINE
AGENCIES THAT APPROVED THE
DEAL.
THE IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL BY
BUT ENDING THE INVESTIGATION
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF COCAINE
IN THE U.S. AND BUILDING UP
THEIR BASE OF TERROR.
HILLARY CLINTON WAS SECRETARY
OF STATE AT THE TIME.
THE CLINTON CLAIMS THESE ARE
ALL EFFORTS BY TRUMP TO DIVERT
ATTENTION FROM ROBERT
MUELLER'S SPECIAL COUNSEL.
TUCKER?
>> Tucker: TRACE GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU.
CONGRESSMAN JOINING US,
REPUBLICAN REPRESENTING
FLORIDA.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN HEAR
ME --
>> I GOT YOU.
JUST HEARD YOU.
>> Tucker: EXCELLENT.
PRIVATE CITIZEN FOR A LONG
TIME.
SHE HAS BEEN OUT OF POLITICS
IN EFFECT FOR A YEAR.
WHY NOW?
WHY IS THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THESE DO YOU THINK FOR THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY?
>> THERE MAY HAVE BEEN ACTS
THAT OCCURRED AT THE STATE
SECURITY CONCERN FOR THE
STORY YOU JUST MENTIONED.
IT'S NOT JUST COCAINE BEING
TRAFFICKED.
TRAFFICKERS IN SOUTH AMERICA
TO MOVE OPIUM, HEROIN AND TO
AND THE INVESTIGATION THAT WAS
GOING ON TO DEGRADE THESE
NETWORKS, TO DEGRADE THE
COLLUSION BETWEEN HEZBOLLAH
AND SOUTH AMERICAN NARCO
TRAFFICKERS WAS SMOTHERED BY
THE PEOPLE OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
THERE IS A SUSPICION THAT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT LED BY
HILLARY CLINTON HAD A ROLE IN
LIMITING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE'S
ACCESS TO INFORMATION ABOUT
HEZBOLLAH BEING FUNDED AND THE
OPERATIONS IN THIS COUNTRY
BECAUSE THEY WANTED THE
IRANIAN NUCLEAR DEAL SO BAD
SOUTH AMERICA TO RECRUIT
PEOPLE AND THEN TO SEND THEM
TO THE UNITED STATES TO DO
HARM.
>> Tucker: SO THAT IS ONE OF
THE INVESTIGATION INTO THAT.
IT DOES SEEM IF TRUE FIRST OF
ALL, HARD TO DEFEND.
BUT SECOND IT HAS OBVIOUS
NATIONAL SECURITY IMPLICATIONS
FOR THE COUNTRY.
CLINTON FOUNDATION.
>> WELL, THE ACCUSATION IS
THAT THE CLINTON FOUNDATION
WAS MERELY A MONEY LAUNDERING
OPERATION WHERE PEOPLE PAID TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE STATE
DEPARTMENT.
THERE WERE NOTATIONS ON
PARTICULAR DOCUMENTS AND BIDS
WHERE PEOPLE WOULD WRITE
F.O.B.
TO THE CLINTON FOUNDATION AND
THAT IS TYPE OF THING WE HAVE
TO KNOW ABOUT NOW.
NOT TO EXERCISE REVENGE ON
DEFEATED PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE BUT TO MAKE SURE WE
DON'T HAVE PEOPLE ACTING AS
VENDORS ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA NOT
ARE FRIENDS OR DONORS TO THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
THAT WHOLE OPERATION WAS FALSE
FROM DAY ONE OBVIOUSLY.
WHY IS IT TAKING SO LONG TO
GET THE INVESTIGATIONS
UNDERWAY?
>> YOU KNOW WE HAVE BEEN
CALLING FOR THIS FOR OVER FIVE
MONTHS.
20 MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE SENT A
LETTER TO JEFF SESSIONS SAYING
WE HAVE TO LOOK INTO THESE
THINGS BECAUSE OF THE ONGOING
SECURITY CONCERNS.
FINALLY NOW WE HAVE HILLARY
CLINTON DEALING WITH
SEND AN "I'M WITH HER T-SHIRT"
TO HILLARY CLINTON'S CELL
MATE.
>> Tucker: SO YOU THINK SHE
IS CRIMINALLY EXPOSED
POTENTIALLY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IF PEOPLE WERE TAKING BRIBES
AND AS A CONSEQUENCE OF THE
BRIBE ENGAGING IN ACTIONS THEY
WOULDN'T OTHERWISE ENGAGE IN,
THAT IS A CRIME.
YOU CAN'T DO IT IN THE UNITED
CONSEQUENCES.
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE THE SUBJECT
OF THE SHOW.
AND WOULD HAVE BEEN FOUND OUT
OTHERWISE WE HAVE TO REMEDIATE
THE HARM THAT THE CLINTON
CAUSED THIS COUNTRY.